all right y'all we are back with G
Brooks and gratitude with G and
celebration of Thanksgiving
week so Community is a it's a word that
kind of encompasses a lot it could be
like the community you sound you
surround yourself with it could be where
you live like what is what is what are
you grateful for about well you know
your community on tour is the band and
crew right that's your second family
yeah so now the crazy thing we're
opening a Friends in Low Places Bar down
a Lower Broadway right I know very
excited now all of a sudden you you
think about cuz I've always played in
Hony Tonks we have our whole lives but
the truth is the community in a honky
ton in a bar yeah forgive me for using
the word church but this is where you
come to not be alone this is where you
come to share your problems raise a beer
together celebrate mourn maybe sometimes
or get Rowdy what amen yeah um so wait
you have a big show this weekend yes yes
it's the day after um Thanksgiving yes
Black Friday so uh for the first time I
ever the NFL is doing a Black Friday
football game yeah I don't know how long
it took us to think of that I know but I
just got into football so I'm so excited
there you go and so Amazon always does
the concerts after the Thursday night
football games bless you and it's it's
they they're doing the game after the
Friday night one yeah and they said hey
man would you do that concert I said I
would love to do it we're opening the
bar at the exact same time so we're
going to go into friends and Low Places
Bar the first time ever and we're going
to do a dive bar concert in there we'll
play some new music and then of course
the old stuff it'll be I'm so mad I'm
not going to be
there that's that's going to be
incredible how do you get in you're
going to love this uh we we just
launched the big 615 the global country
music station it's awesome so what I
love about it is the only way you get in
you just listen and you register so the
people that you're going to play for
that night they they don't have to have
a lot of money they don't have to have a
certain uh look about them or where they
work it's just luck of the draw so it's
going to be fantastic it's funny look at
the real fans on that really want to be
there amen the Friends in Low Places
that's it I like it we all about
Connection in the show it's like it's
kind of my thing in life I just love
connecting with people and talking and
communicating um but what are what
connections are you like so Greatful for
in life obviously Miss Yearwood yeah I
can tell you this I learned this a long
time ago the greatest gifts that you
will leave this planet with are
relationships not money not anything
like that it's just relationships and
you never know when you're going to call
on them and people say you know I can
carry the world on my shoulders I'm
telling you right now you cannot carry
the world on the shoulders until someone
has carried you you just C man it's it's
that that whole empathy of understanding
how people are and that's what it's all
about man so I'm in for that empathy is
a we got a rule on the farm that you
can't say a word you can't spell so I
can't say that word again but we get it
once but that is the work that's
incredible I love that role so radio it
was really important for me as a kid
because one I couldn't afford to buy a
lot of music when I was younger was
radio really important for you growing
up yeah very very important for me um
it's it's one of those things you you
know we we had G well again before you
were born we had gas Wars and they would
give away stuff to try and get you to
come over to their their gas stations
and stuff yeah and we got this
transistor radio and somehow I
confiscated it became mine so you'd lay
there in bed at night we got the Opera
on wky am. at that point and then there
was a there was a radio station called
the cat that was coming out that did all
the rock Classics oh yeah and so you'd
lay there in bed at night Well
everybody's asleep with that little
thing in your ear and that's what you'd
go to bed with is just listening to
music yeah oh me too well speaking of
like finding music I love that we talked
about it a little we touched on it you
have like three channels yes so the
tailgate one is like more of a tailgate
party that's your Vibe it's it just and
615 is country music the entire family
yeah I love that 615 with that that's
still my number sense yeah and then the
other one is the G Channel what's the
difference between that one the G
channel is just as screwed up as you
could possibly be that's my favorite
it's just it it doesn't matter because
here's my theory you play like James
Taylor you play Everything 100% great
artists can follow great artist great
songs can follow great songs Myrtle
Haggard and Beyonce can play back to
back I agree I agree great so we you're
G to love mine yeah that's the same
that's the same thing I love it first of
all y'all just singing over there we
didn't get to play the whole thing but
like you I mean speaking of harmonies
and just beautiful music and everything
how do you how do you do that work
Harmony balance all that in your life
how do you do that oh I I think what you
do is you just run I mean somebody's got
a plan don't try and don't try and have
your own PL somebody's got a plan and
just look for your open doors Karma our
friendship together I I can't tell you
how hard it was and how long it took me
to text you to go hey I got this new
song and I would love for you to say
it's so hard for me to ask okay but I
want I want I want you guys how long it
was for me to
respond we can check it on my phone I
can look at it and it was literally I
was like oh and I was like yes I was
like all capital letter all capitals
with exclam
Point what the hell it doesn't matter
how long you've been in this business
when someone you love treat you back
like that thank you that was oh my God
that freaking awesome I will be there
anytime for you or Miss year with y'all
are my favorites man and the song I said
this um earlier this song okay it's
called the ship in the bottle it's so
beautiful I said yes before I even heard
the song I'm pretty sure and this song
like when I went in the studio and first
of all you producing me always makes me
want Christmas turkey it's like it's
like like it's like it like I get I get
so nervous like I'm like it's happened
twice to me but I was so nervous and I
was just trying to be cool and anyway
but I how you had me sing nobody lets me
really just sing you know and and not
always reach for the Raptors not always
like do all the and it was just it made
me feel as cool as Linda ronat which is
one of my favorite singers and artist
ever and like that's the vibe is kind of
very it feels like it could been could
have been released in like the 7 like
yeah it's so cool it feels good it's
just a kind of a beachy thing and what I
love the saying about it is just this
guy feels like he's holding a woman back
you know and then I start thinking about
my own relationship with she go no
wonder of this sounds so natural to sing
right because it's just it's so good um
she's the ship that should be out on the
water and he's the bottle he just he
just likes to
drink but also the imagery of that like
keeping in it's so we have to do it you
you were texting me you're like should
we sing it live and I was like we should
do a little bit we should do a little
bit of it it's so beautiful okay let's
do
it we played this uh every album comes
out we play for the songwriters and
there was a songwriter young lady that
was in the chair listening she's in the
captain's chair hearing it and I can
tell she's starting to get emotional
when the song's playing and I'm going
you still got it right I'm so because
she turns around and grabs my arm with
these beautiful eyes and goes my God
that's Kelly Clarkson isn't it
which is never going to happen so
fabulous no man when your voice comes
out on this record everybody goes and
everybody knows who it is too whatever
but I love this song and thank you for
asking
[Music]
[Applause]
me thank you guys y'all have a great
guys I'm going
home